I think a lot of people and myself
included wanted to see her do it against
the athleticism do it against the best
of South Carolina I mean South Carolina
you see them there they are just huge
and big and athletic and for her to be
able to get her shot off and do what she
did I mean a 41 point at the at the
biggest state at the biggest stage where
you are
the key to ever to to be stopped on
every possession for her to do that I
mean
listen she made me a Believer yesterday
and I don't do this but like mentioning
somebody what she's do what she's doing
in the tournament is a la stuff what
Steph did except now she's she's in and
after the final right that's a great
comparison